Vsauce Kevin here let's get inspired by
pee light meat snack the sound of
running water may make you want to pee
because of a conditioned association
with running water and going to the
bathroom not just with the sound of
peeing itself but the flush of the
toilet and washing your hands and it
might not just be sounds placing images
of waterfalls above urinals has proven
effective in helping shy bladders the
standard read meaning stop and green
meeting go at traffic lights comes
directly from railroad signals although
green initially meant caution and white
meant go that system changed because of
an incident in which a red lens fell out
making a red light look like a white
light and causing a terrible crash these
colors go back further to industrial
equipment featuring red light for stop
and green while it was running but red
has been thought of as a danger signal
for thousands of years because it's the
color of blood people often describe
exotic meat like snake frog and
alligator as all tasting like chicken
possibly due to evolution chicken and
birds in general are widely believed to
be direct descendants of dinosaurs
sharing a common meaty ancestor with
modern snakes lizards and turtles called
die opsins
chicken also has a bland taste because
of a lack of fat and the type of muscle
is fast fiber allowing these chicken
tasting animals to make short fast
movements eating popcorn at the movie
theater is commonplace because during
the Great Depression in the u.s. movie
theater owners needed a new way to make
money
they added snack sales like the cheaply
available popcorn to supplement lower
attendance and ultimately stay in
business
roaming popcorn vendors gained
popularity in 1885 and they often set up
near crowds like outside of a movie
theater so - the ight slap in and and -
the EM and what we're left with is
appeal and eat snack such as the orange
a citrus fruit that was named orange 200
years before the color orange was named
orange before that linguists believe
that people referred to
this color simply as yellow red and as
always thanks for watching